[Music]
hi everyone I am Matthew Grossman and
today we are going to discuss typescript
and I realized this talk kind of sounds
like I'm about to go on an indictment of
typescript
but actually I love typescript I adore
typescript I just want to kind of talk
about it holistically to convince you
that it is worth your time
so whoo my my name is Mathew Gerstmann I
am a software engineer at Dropbox I live
and work in New York you can find me on
Twitter and for some reason people think
following me on Twitter is a good idea
so I'm gonna tell you why that's a bad
idea first of all I tweet a lot about
Taylor Swift
this is me whenever I go on a bad date I
also tweet a lot about Harry Potter this
is a replica of me as a teenager just
very angsty and finally I wrote a book
on how to buy Broadway tickets and that
is my shameless plug so thank you for
indulging me let's go to typescript now
so the reason I put this talk together
was at the beginning of the year I
noticed a lot of Twitter like Twitter
chatter about typescript people were
really really excited about typescript
people were saying that their new year's
resolutions were to learn typescript and
someone was like hey it's been two weeks
we should all be experts by now right
cuz that's how tech works and then
someone's like I'm gonna try to embrace
it
I really appreciated how Jane Wong
stepped in and was just like why is
everyone saying this this kind of came
out of nowhere and it wasn't just
Twitter right it was Korra and read it
and like medium and just anywhere you
could find you could write an opinion
someone was writing about typescript but
this actually isn't new at all this is
the Google trend for typescript interest
over the past seven years
so since 2013 and you'll see it's been
steadily increasing in popularity since
then so this isn't really new and
something I've seen a lot of is people
like to compare typescript to
CoffeeScript because they're both
popular languages that add some
fundamental new thing to the language
that compile down to JavaScript but
CoffeeScript was three years old when it
died whereas typescript is turning
soon so I don't think we can
meaningfully compare them anymore and
CoffeeScript I know a lot of people like
to talk about it and like poorly now
that because it's just legacy code but
that's what gave us promises that's what
gave us and lambda is it gave us a lot
of really interesting things at the time
so today I want to get past the hype and
the reason for that is I think when we
are talking about our tools we spend way
too much time looking like this and
instead we should really be looking like
this but I don't have any Futurama fans
here yeah sweet cool I will not so we're
gonna go into the ugly parts and then
we're gonna talk about why I think you
should use it anyway because I want to
convince you that this is a tool worth
using and learning and frankly that's
not gonna happen if we don't talk about
like the bad parts of it so let's take
ten steps back first what is a type well
a type is an attribute of data that
tells the computer how the programmer
intends to use it
and even if you don't work in typescript
you're probably familiar with some basic
types in JavaScript we have boolean
which are true or false we have numbers
so one 73.5 whatever it is we have
strings which are you know groups of
characters it could be the entire text
of Harry Potter which I would put in a
string we also have arrays which are
lists of things and we have objects
which are maps these are all types that
I hope you're familiar with we also have
some falsey types right you've probably
most of you have dealt with something
with null or undefined being different
and that typescript decided hey let's
make this a little more confusing and
add never and void which we're not
really going to cover today but know
they exist types can also be derived
from other types so we can do things
like say the type of this is only one of
these specific strings like it's an enum
or we could say it's an object of this
shape and the final thing I need you to
know about for price typescript types is
any and what any is is it's an escape
hatch it basically says hey typescript
you don't know how to type this or I
don't know how to type this but either
way I really don't want you to do
anything here so just trust me I'm a
doctor I got
so what exactly is typescript well type
strip script is a strict superset of
JavaScript strict might need a little
asterisk now because someone came up
with a nifty little counter example but
let's go with it's a superset of
JavaScript and it looks like this in
fact if you look at this code the only
thing that makes this different from
traditional JavaScript are these type
annotations right here these strings and
boolean x' so i have a function that
takes a string and if i run this code in
my editor or if i compile it using
typescript it will work just fine when i
pass it a string but if i pass it a
boolean it's gonna fail by the way
gryffindor is for people who peaked in
high school I've very strong opinions
typescript is also smart like really
really smart so we have these Dom
functions document get elements by tag
name and we need to pass it different
strings and return different types of
elements based on what type of string we
pass right because eight tags have href
swear as divs don't and P tags have
their own attributes so we want to
return a completely different type based
on what string is passed to this
function
typescript also makes big refractors
really easy and that's where i'm gonna
show you some of it so let me let me
switch into let me do mirror for you
cool so I have this code here and you
can see I have a list of slytherins I
said I was a big Harry Potter fan and in
what we're doing is we have Taylor Swift
who I've already told you I love we have
lin-manuel Miranda who wrote Hamilton
which is a great musical and we have
Severus Snape he was kind of a pain but
he's famous thank you and let's say we
want to add a prop we want to add a
points prop so we're gonna we're gonna
put points here and we are going to type
that out and this is super cool Villa's
code immediately picks up that it can't
find this variable name which it could
probably do in traditional JavaScript I
don't know we'll ask Brian afterwards
but that's not really typescript
specific so let's let's add it to our
function signature now this is where we
have an actual typescript error property
points does not exist on type props with
children's Slytherin props and this is
the type of error message that you have
to learn how to read but what this is
effectively saying is Slytherin props
which is right over here does not
contain points and this is probably the
coolest thing about typescript in my
opinion if I add this prop you can see
the second I type a P or any letter it
lit up at the bottom with this red and
the error message here is that we are
missing the property points on all of
these components and if you consider
these are all in this file but imagine
if I had my component library on one
side of my application and there you sit
your there usages on the other you will
catch these things very very quickly so
let's give out some points shall we
so Taylor Swift currently really just
had a great album I'm very proud of her
so we're gonna give her a whole bunch of
points when Manuel miranda is literally
printing money at the moment so he can
have more and I don't like Snape so he
can have negative three points cool and
by the way if you were curious if you
want to know what happens when you take
this stupid little example and turn it
into a fully fledged web site you end up
building this Slytherin dev which I did
for another talk for fun fun fact Brian
is not mentioned here because he has a
ravenclaw but his wife Nicki who is
present is there
and also Nikko one of our other great
speakers is on here as well because she
has a slower end so that's just fun and
I wanted to share that now let's talk
about vanilla JavaScript right so
typescript claims to be incremental and
it is especially at first so if I want
to make a string muggle Vernon Dursley
or just Dursley and if I want to do
yelling muddle o Const yelling muggle
equals muggle you'll see I immediately
get da completion on every function
that's on this string because I'm using
typescript that's that's the kind of
thing that you don't have right away so
let's let's call to uppercase which is
great and let's say I want to get a
subset of this string right I want to
call slice but let's say I make a type I
type splice well it gives me the great
error property splice does not exist on
type string did you mean slice and
that's the kind of thing that just like
we is amazing that when you get to start
taking it for granted because I could
have easily made this typo right and
then that would have appeared in my
browser as opposed to in my editor or
even if I'm lucky my terminal so we've
got that but these are just strings
right let's do something a little more
complicated let's make a wizard so we
have a wizard and we want to do wizard
name equals Harry Potter well this is
interesting this is totally valid
JavaScript this time and it says
property name does not exist on type
empty object that's a little obnoxious
okay so let's let's fix that so let's
make a type it's like a wizard type and
wizards have names so we'll do that and
we will add the type annotation and now
we get a new error now it's saying
property name is missing on type empty
object but required in type wizards so
okay so we have to do it this way we put
the name in the thing and even though
every example you just saw was totally
valid JavaScript typescript is making us
do it this way just because it needs to
infer these types let's look at another
example how many of you use lodash
either willingly or but grudgingly yeah
everyone most people use lodash for
something right so we
Partlow - and we get the same super cool
docked completion on low - which is an
external library and I think whoa - is a
particularly cool example because of how
powerful the types are here so you'll
see right now it thinks that I might
want to pass a collection of strings to
this but the second I give it an array
it's gonna assume that it is something
already like and it could be anything
and when I start typing numbers it knows
that it's a number and if I type string
it knows that it's a string or a number
so not only that but in my predicate it
knows that value is of type number so if
I had slice to this it's gonna say it
doesn't exist on number so let's just
make this work for values greater than
10 cool sweet otherwise they're not that
was the thing I showed you so one of the
takeaways I want you to have is that
typescript is gonna get in your way for
the first few months how many of you
have used one of these functions low -
get or low - set yeah they're kind of
becoming less popular especially as
optional chaining is a thing but these
are virtually impossible to type getting
the type so these allow you to
arbitrarily drill into an object via a
string and just kind of do something
there and it's really hard to get that
right in typescript and it's we're just
gonna kind of give up that tool
what about tests right like we have to
write tests tests are gonna require very
well mock data or you're gonna be using
lots of any's what if you want to test
the absence of a prop on a component
especially if you're writing a library
like where you don't know how your
consumers are gonna use it or if they're
gonna be using typescript you're gonna
have to start throwing in any's what a
lot of things come down to is advanced
JavaScript ends up translating to
advanced typescript an example I love to
give our higher-order components how
many of you are still using higher-order
components yeah it's like they're
they're not as popular as they used to
be but they are one of the most
interesting type cases I think because
we have a wrapped component which is
inside of the hoc it's receiving props
from it and then it also needs to
receive regular props from the outside
which may or may not need to be
by the HSE and just to make this more
complicated the rap component internally
needs to be able to receive all the
props it knew about and then also the
HSC props this is really really hard to
type you need to know about generics you
need to know about intersections you
need to know about discriminated unions
and I don't expect you to know any of
those things today you just want dot
completion on your strings like that's
what you want early on so if you're
interested I wrote a blog post you can
check that out on how to type a
higher-order component it took me two
weeks in 2017 because there wasn't a lot
of documentation back patent the other
thing is typescript is not sound so what
I mean by sound
well soundness implies that we can know
at compile time that our code is safe to
run and if it doesn't have that property
it's considered not sound and the reason
for this is anyone can put in any
anywhere in your codebase and remember
it always said any is just like AI trust
me trust me I'm a doctor it's an escape
hatch it's actually a little more like
this glad I got something cool anyway so
a great example of something that's very
hard to type is react context so we have
a provider and a consumer and this magic
data flow in the middle and we can't
really type that magic data flow we
can't we can trust that reacts gonna do
the right thing but the best we can do
is pin the type on the provider and on
the consumer and hope for the best
react Redux takes this problem to the
next level we have to deal with context
and then we have thunks which are
functions returning functions and
inferring what each of those levels
return and then when we're dispatching
with middleware we're doing all this
complicated typing and it just starts to
get really challenging and all of this
is because typescript is a strict
superset of JavaScript
we're bolting on types on to an untyped
language this is totally valid
JavaScript it's stupid but it's valid so
this function if it gets hairy as an
argument
it returns seven if it gets Ron it
returns undefined forgets hermione
returns an object and if it gets
anything else that returns wizards and
you may be thinking why would I write a
function that returns four different
types
but I actually showed you that at the
beginning of the talk most Dom API s
will return one of many different types
based on what string you pass to it
they're just not all as like as
contrived as this one so here's where I
tell you that all of this is still worth
it typescript is just another tool
typescript is not a silver bullet and
what it does do is it eliminates an
entire class of bugs how many of you
have seen this error message in your
console just like expect the entire
audience to raise their hands right of
course like at some point you've seen
this and nine out of ten times type
scripts gonna cut this out for you
because it's just gonna no undefined is
not there when you try to access that
property same thing for this one when
you try to call a function that isn't
there it's gonna catch that in your
editor with those red squiggly lines and
not just like these things what about
when the interface changes what about
when I add a prop to a component that
someone else on my team is using and I
forgot to tell them it's gonna kill me
in advance when this happens and this
becomes an even bigger issue when you're
talking about the scale of a company
like Dropbox we have hundreds of
engineer's working on the same codebase
we have millions of lines of typescript
hundreds of features and just to make it
more challenging we have for engineering
offices in three time zones so we have
to coordinate well typescript is a core
part of our front-end workflow and I
want to show you some cool examples that
you might not have thought of one of my
favorite ones is library upgrades so
there's this great typings library on
github called definitely typed and what
exists here are all of these types for
any third-party library you can think of
if it's not in the library itself it's
almost definitely undef initely typed
and the first thing we do when we go to
swap out to upgrade a library is we swap
out the types so let's say we're going
from react 16 10 to 11 we will swap out
the types and then if there are any
breaking changes in the API we'll catch
those almost immediately because it'll
be in the typing layer and our compile
will fail so the very first thing we fix
is compilation some examples of the
types of things that change or what
happens when a feature gets deprecated
what happens when we lose old context or
we get rid of old refs or we get rid of
component we'll do something and then
also the types are changing right like
sometimes function signatures change
sometimes we add something or remove
something and then often the types just
get better a lot of the times someone
will bump the types indefinitely typed
and they will catch something for us
that is just some of the edge case where
undefined was passed somewhere and you
didn't even think of it honestly at our
scale I don't know how we would upgrade
wipe upgrade libraries without
typescript we're talking millions of
lines typescript also allows us to place
constraints on our engineers and you
might be thinking I don't want
constraints on me I want the freedom to
do whatever I want and I'd like to give
you a metaphor so we have the beautiful
charles bridge in prague and the
simplest way with the fewest constraints
to build this bridge would have been to
dump a ton of concrete into the river
maybe at the time several hundred years
ago dumped a bunch of stone into the
river and that would build a bridge that
lets us cross it but we couldn't have
boats get through we would ruin wildlife
we would do terrible things to the
environment and maybe we do that so when
we're building bridges we do proper
constraints and we want that with our
engineers too so remember I talked about
react upgrades we often want to test the
latest version in production so we want
to make sure that the newest latest
thing is going to run against the code
that we have but we might need to
rollback and here's the problem with
that developers will start using new
features as soon as we let them remember
when hooks came out this is a simulation
of our web platform team dealing with
all of our engineers excited about hooks
they are simba they are just trying to
stay ahead of the pack to make this work
so to solve this we roll out the latest
version of react behind a feature gate
but we keep the types of the previous
versions so that at the compilation step
they just can't use hooks until we know
that we're not gonna roll back and then
once we're confident we'll add the types
and this process sounds heavy it's
actually it lasts maybe a week it's just
you know we want to run latest react
against ten or twenty or thirty percent
of our users until we bump it up to a
hundred and leave it there
another super cool thing we do is we
restrict lodash usage so there's a lot
of functions in lodash that are no
longer really relevant they kind of made
it into es5 or they're just like kind of
heavy or whatever we don't want that and
also look that's just 25k if you ship
the whole bundle so you definitely want
a smaller bundle excuse me so what we do
is we have this Taipings firewall that
prevents engineers from using functions
that we don't want in our bundle and if
they want to add it they submit a PR and
it's a one-liner and we probably say yes
if we think it's a good idea but
otherwise we just like kind of defaults
and not having this dependency and not
sending down this extra code we wrote a
really great blog post about all that
and how we did that migration you can
read that one later but what about for
small teams right like I've been talking
about hundreds of engineers but your
team is probably 5 or 10 or 20 or maybe
it's just you maybe it's just you
writing code and some people are gonna
claim the typescript gives you free
documentation and I'm not gonna tell you
that I think you still need Docs
especially to convey why you did things
some people are gonna claim that
typescript is gonna give you free tests
and I don't want to make that claim
either you absolutely should be writing
integration test and end-to-end tests
and like dealing with that but here's
what typescript is gonna give you it's
gonna give you contract validation
across the board so this is kind of a
standard application right we have our
API and then we have our data layer
which might be redux
it might be Apollo it might be hooks
what we might be using hooks use reducer
whatever it doesn't matter it's probably
here then we have our components which
are a little smarter and are doing some
business logic and then we have kind of
our dumber components in the front our
component library and we can enforce
contracts across this so a contract is a
precise and verifiable interface for
software components and the most
important part of this is that it's
verifiable so for example on our API an
engineer who's probably writing in
Python or go or rust is gonna want to
make a change to some endpoint and what
we do is we compile those types using a
tool that we've open-source called stone
we have typescript types then and they
won't know immediately before they merge
their code if they're going to break
someone's usage somewhere on the front
end similarly on the entire opposite end
of the stack with our component library
if you've got a Slytherin component and
you want to add a prop that is now
required or you want to remove a prop or
add the type or change the type we're
gonna catch that across the usages
throughout our millions of lines of code
and then not only that but engineers can
do this within their own features which
is super nice in fact I want to show you
an example of that so I wrote this small
sample app and the first thing you'll
notice is that we have this type user
and user has a user ID which is a number
and a name which is a string we have
this function which might be
auto-generated from our tooling that
call it's called fetch users and it
returns a promise of list of user so
we've brought this type from the back
end to the front end using typescript
and automated toy in our Redux layer
we're gonna want to dispatch actions
that can fetch the user and the payload
is gonna be of type users so this type
is slowly propagating across the system
inside the function we are returning a
type which has guaranteed that payload
then in our actual store where we're
storing the data we are still using this
user type that came from some arbitrary
place in the backend this could have
been defined in a protobuf this could
have been defined very close to the
database but we are propagating this
across our system now here is what I
like to call a contract shift because
what we're doing is we are taking the
store or the shape of the store and that
has a user in it and now we are
returning a string that's what that type
on the far right is so our view which
really doesn't care about the backend or
how any of this works has this name prop
and all it's receiving is a string and
it can just spit that out to the user so
this type this user type from the
backend is being propagated everywhere
it's needed up until we have a contract
that says hey we need a string for type
user let's trade and then we give that
out to the view I also like to argue
that typescript increases in value over
time
this is kind of just like a contrived
graph where I said the number of lines
of code that you could generate by
yourself over three years which is
probably 20,000 maybe it's 50,000 maybe
it's 100,000 you could write a lot of
code by yourself and what happens if the
team becomes five or ten you're easily
producing hundreds of thousands of lines
of code very quickly are you gonna
remember how every part of your
application integrates with every other
part of your application how many of you
have written a login form at some point
in time as the very first thing you did
and then forgotten about it it's kind of
a common thing so what I like is that
unlike tests typescript gets in your way
it's in the middle of your editor it's
in the middle of your compiler now it's
not a silver bullet like I said I want
you writing tests I want you doing code
review and I want you thinking about
architecture but I would argue that the
metric for success on a code base is how
few things you need to keep in your head
at any given point in time and
typescript allows you to forget about
other caught parts of your code base and
really the only cost is learning it so
thank you so much my name is matthew
gerstmann and i think we can do
questions Thank You Matthew
we have questions do you think duck
typing is an anti-pattern so one of the
interesting things about typescript
especially is that it uses structural
typing so I've been in cases where I did
something like I had two types that were
exactly the same and we decided to split
them because they might change da is
duck typing an ansi pattern the answer
is depends on your use case like most
things I don't really have a strong
opinion here chances are if your UI
props and you are very back of your your
stack props or just function signature
are exactly the same that they're
probably going to diverge at some point
and maybe make two separate types but
you can also start off with one the
biggest thing I would avoid is justly
hasty abstractions where you abstract
things that don't necessarily need to be
abstracted why should I choose
typescript overflow honestly I would
just push you to use a typed anything I
do not have a stake in this holy war I
work for Dropbox not Microsoft or
Facebook so I really don't have a stake
in it I can say in my experience
typescript has a much stronger community
it has much stronger third-party types
and it seems to be getting more support
but if flow is working for you like I'm
not going to tell you to migrate your
codebase keep using flow this one you
might have to help me how much different
is typescript do there's this native
panting and weights in text show
significantly slow performance with big
data structures interesting okay so
typescript does the job for you that
Babel traditionally does which down
compiles your latest es next code with
all the latest features into something
that the browser can serve it can even
do es 3 but normally it's doing s 5 I
actually don't know the performance
implications of using typescript verse
basmala versus the native one I would
imagine that the native async/await is
probably the fastest one if you're in an
environment where you're really
optimizing for that you could serve the
async/await as is but I don't think
typescript really has much of an impact
compared to compared to any of the other
options you're gonna choose max is how
typescript works with not type
dependencies yeah so if it's not undef
initely typed which is rare what you do
is you make kind of an index file for
yourself it's called a DTS file and it's
similar to a header file in other
languages and what you do there is you
say this is the library and you can you
can you have two options you can either
take the time to type it yourself and
maybe you want to commit that to the
outside world or you can just say just
trust me when I use this library and
it's not going to be type safe there but
that's one of the nice things is that
it's incremental so you don't
immediately have to type your whole
codebase it's also really useful to
think of this not just for not type
dependencies but for just parts of your
code base that aren't typed a lot of the
time when people do migrations they tend
to start very inside and then move
outwards
there was a great talk from someone at
Airbnb I believe about how they did that
migration we gonna do last two questions
Matt so how sleep is the learning curve
for typescript um so I hope you saw some
of that in the incremental stuff that at
first it's very simple like you have
strings and you have numbers and you
have primitives it does get complicated
very quickly like you don't have to go
from 1 to 11 like on the you know knob
from 1 to 10 but you do get to 6 rather
fast and the reason for that is
third-party libraries like lodash or
react or what have you
those are gonna require sufficiently
complex types to be statically typed now
you can always make the trade-off I want
my code to be slightly less type safe
and get some of the benefits of
typescript that is that is totally a
valid thing but if you're going for that
like perfect typing all the time like
yes there's a steep learning curve so I
said last two questions but we have two
more questions that are both competing
so will there ever be in Tigger type and
typescript ask Brian hold after I leave
the stage all right and my goodness and
then last one how do you pass generic
type into functional components yeah I
do that all the time see you you can do
what you end up doing is you do what
Const it's easier if I actually type
this out you do Const react compile type
of the react component and then you can
pass a generic to it I don't think you
can actually do generics with standard
function space name of the function
signature but you can do it with the
stored in a variable syntax so there is
one way to do it but it doesn't work the
other one all right that's all the time
we have thank you so much to us Matthew
Kurtzman thank you so much
[Music]